buddy we're the master Dome what the
is going on right now bro you still
leaving your nose that's where you get
swamped dog that's the one thing you
gotta cover got a mouth sword you're
trying to hide what's going on you made
a choice to commit to this and I want to
know why he pulled it up like that's
gonna quiet me down that's not the issue
I don't care dog I had covered twice
give it to me a third time I'm a medical
Marvel
is she making you do this stupid if
we're gonna go we have to be safe you
probably got her sick two weeks ago and
she's like don't do that again and then
you're like I don't wear this mask I'm
wearing half the mask how do you know
these people you gonna let her marry
this half mask you're not
married are you because you can't commit
to I knew it I knew it I
knew it didn't I tell you I knew he
wasn't married I answered before he
answered